jamel debbouze vous avez atteint une
notoriété vraiment tout à fait
exceptionnel on voit bien chacune de vos
prises de position sont entendus c'est
une très lourde responsabilité
est-ce que vous vous sentez aussi libre
qu'il y a quatre en cinq ans sa première
fois que j'entends que j'ai une lourde
responsabilité
non je prends pas ça comme une lourde
responsabilité au contraire j'ai fait
les choses naturellement et être que
quand quelque chose m'indigne je le dis
quand quelque chose me rend heureux je
le dis de la même manière après les gens
les enfants ce qu'ils veulent mais mais
j'ai pour moi de des trolls le plus vrai
avec moi possible oui par exemple là on
est dans une dans une période
pré-électorale assez sensible très
difficile chaque camp peut avoir envie
de vous récupérer récupérer un homme
comme comme vous alors est-ce que vous
allez prendre parti vous qui avez mac
avis souvent dénoncé nicolas sarkozy
ouais ouais bien sûr je prends le
parquet le jour du vote je prendrais
parti je ferai quand tout le monde les
avants bavent avant j'attendrai d'être
convaincu ne veut pour l'instant
j'attends d'accord janvier à votre
actualité
d'abord le fait bondir vers quel signe
que la réveiller nicolas sarkozy pas ce
genre entre dans mon pays en suisse avec
johnny hallyday
voilà j'en viens à votre actualité le
fabuleux destin d'indigènes donc je lui
disais à la fois nos baissé aux césars
et puis aux oscars vous avez co produit
ce film vous l'avez littéralement porté
est ce qu est ce que vous vous êtes fier
qu'est ce que vous ressentez la gens
veulent nous faire des bisous sérieux
mais opération opération de
déstabilisation
comment ne pas vous répondre à la
question et je vous assure que c'est le
protégeons je suis je suis d'humeur
bisous 2 c'est à dire que j'ai envie de
faire des bisous à tous mieux je suis
très heureux j'ai l'impression d'avoir
accompli quelque chose
j'ai l'impression que c'était dans le
temps dans donc ça qu on a atteint nos
objectifs
la loi va être votée au sénat ccc
meilleur des oscars après après s'il
cerise c'est la cerise sur le gâteau
d'être d'être reconnus par nos pairs
mais on a fait d'abord pour que le
maximum de gens entente qu'il ya des
gens qui se sont battus aux côtés des
français contre contre le nazisme et et
quand je vois ce qui se passe
monde j'ai là juste l'impression que il
est indispensable de faire ce genre de
film l'autre actualité
c'est donc mardi prochain on vous
retrouve au casino de paris avec une
bande de jeunes comédiens pleins de
talent vous vous aimez jouer au pape un
jackie quartz visé est pas qu elle
faisait porter cette affaire vous sauvez
jacques equity cvc a fait transférer bon
faisait sa chance moi c'est ça c'est
donc au casino avec des jeunes
vous aimez jouer au papa ouais ouais
ouais mais il faut que vous apporte
cette expérience moi j'adore être dans
une dynamique de travail
quand j'ai commencé j'ai commencé par
des scènes ouvertes vous savez on venait
on s'inscrivait le dimanche avec eric et
ramzy dany boon y avec gad elmaleh l'île
d'yeu d'années à l'époque et et je me
souviens que le code que dans les
coulisses on se parlait plus tout seul
chacun dans notre coin à faire des
gestes comme lescure savait avant
l'avant la descente et j'affirme ça
nulle part et j'avais envie de recréer
cette dynamique de travail et et c'était
pas en quoi c'était pas possible et
encore trois quatre ans parce que parce
qu'il n'y avait pas cette génération cet
engouement tendu de la scène et du stand
up en particulier et est aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression que c'est devenu
mouvance presque comme le hip hop que
que que la rue a pris possession de ce
truc et que on n'hésite pas à dans les
halls de bâtiments à faire des joutes
verbales comme comme nous à l'époque
quand on faisait des concours de danse
gégé et j'ai juste l'impression d'y
avoir contribué à cet engouement
donc j'ai envie de perpétrer un volt par
mètre perpétuerait tu rêvais
une dernière question jamais lé debbouze
dont on vous sent encore ce soir très
séducteur très très joueurs vont se dire
d'ailleurs
on peut dire de gros budget l'éternel
ado comme qu'est ce que ces séducteurs
parce que j'ai mis ma belle chemise et
joueurs un éternel ado un éternel ado si
vous voulez je n'ai pas envie de prendre
les choses au sérieux quand il en parle
quand sa part lieu d'être je suis
sérieux et grave cancan quand ça me
demande c'est une énergie d'être sérieux
cce
il faut la vie est une blague pour moi
j'aurais jamais cru me retrouver un jour
ici devant vous c'est exceptionnel ce
qui m'arrive j'en suis conscient je suis
très heureux et j'ai pas envie de
trouver les choses graves et lourdes
c'est pour ça que je suis joueur si vous
voulez un plaisir partagé et merci jamel
debbouze j'ai adoré ce moment c'est
l'événement mondial incontournable
oh là là pour tous les passionnés de
courses hippiques le 86e prix d'amérique
a été remporté aujourd'hui par un jeune
trotteur français de cinq ans le
reportage d'alain dorgans et alexandre
dupont c'est sûr